hi everyone welcome to the daily
homeroom live stream i'm sal from khan
academy uh and i'm super excited about
our guest today so i'm actually just
gonna go through my announcements pretty
fast so that we have as much time with
with tom friedman as possible but before
we start i do like to make my standard
announcement that
remember khan academy is a
not-for-profit uh we only exist through
philanthropic donations from folks like
yourself and i do want to give a special
shout out to several corporations that
stepped up uh when they found out that
we needed to step up more
during this whole crisis special thanks
to bank of america google.org att fastly
and novartis and the many other
corporations and foundations that have
been supporting us even pre-coveted and
we were running at a deficit before this
has definitely helped but we continue to
run into deficit because of the traffic
on our servers and all the programs that
we're trying to accelerate because of
kovid so if you are in a position to do
so please think about donating
so with that i'm super excited excited
to introduce our guest tom friedman i
think someone who doesn't need much of
an introduction a famous columnist an
author from the new york times tom great
great to see you
celebrate to be with you it's great
so i'm glad you you joined i don't think
there's a lot to talk about not much
interesting going on in the world but i
figure you know we're good at killing
time
where do we start i am curious
you know your vantage point of all of
the things that are now kind of have
been thrown up in the air from
the health care crisis to the economic
crisis obviously even there's an
education crisis maybe there's political
stuff going on and obviously khan
academy we're a non-political
organization so we try to stay a little
bit clear about some of those
conversations but i'm curious
from your point of view as a columnist
and an author you know if you've written
books about globalization the world is
flat all of these things
what do you think is the biggest
aha of this moment
um i think there are two cell that
really are shaping how i cover this
story um
the first is um
you know my uh my youngest daughter
natalie actually is executive producer
of all things considered weekend edition
on npr so i never miss it and on easter
sunday they did a roundup of pastors
sermons from around the country
and um i particularly uh was struck by
michael curry's a sermon from the
national cathedral
because he ended it with a song
he started singing
he's got the whole world
in his hands he's got the whole wide
world
in his hands he's got the whole world
in his hands he's got the whole world in
his
hands
i think what is
for me i'm a pretty good singer
i don't think so but that was that was
in in any way but yeah please continue
what is the uber story for me sell what
has really shaped my thinking more than
anything about this story
is that just substitute he for she
for the first time mother nature
has us all in her hands for the first
time
our generation of human species
because i don't think any of us are
virtually any of us were here in 1918
the last time she had us all in her
hands last time there was a global
pandemic for the first time we all are
facing
one of nature's challenges
together as a species
and mother nature um throws fastballs at
us uh
droughts floods wildfires
germs viruses pandemics
and these are the way um ultimately uh
natural selection happens for for plants
and animals this is how she starts out
the fittest
um and this is the first time all of us
together have faced this kind of
challenge this kind of fastball
now um
so mother nature
um
one of the things you always have to
keep in mind is she she actually doesn't
reward the smartest
uh she also doesn't reward the strongest
she actually rewards the most adaptive
when she throws her fastballs
who can actually adapt best
and in the face of a pandemic
she really is saying to us
i reward three kinds of adaptation
first i reward humility do you respect
my virus
because if you don't respect my virus it
will hurt you or someone you love
second are you coordinated
in facing my virus because i evolved my
viruses over millennia
to find any crack in your immune system
so unless you are really coordinated in
your response
my virus will will find that crack
and lastly because mother nature herself
is just chemistry biology and physics
she says i only reward adaptation
strategies that are based on chemistry
biology and physics if your adaptation
strategy is based on politics ideology
or an election schedule um uh it won't
be effective
and so for me cell that's kind of the
uber framework at which i look at
everything i i judge the responses and
um uh and and is the lens to which i'm
doing my analysis
and actually there's a ton of questions
already coming in i do want to remind
everyone watching if you have any
questions for especially tom but
including me
feel free to put them on the message
boards on youtube and facebook we have
team members who are going to surface
that to us
but given what you just said which i
think is a really good way of thinking
about it because so many times we're
kind of caught up in our human bubble
but we are on this planet and there are
forces
that can humble us very very very
quickly
how do you think
well let me ask a question you know how
do you think this is going to play out
how do you think it's going to play out
in the short term and what do you think
are going to be the maybe the medium and
long-term implications of all of this
well what i would say is that um what
you see
are three broad responses
of adaptation playing out in the world
today um
so one let's call it um the super
efficient
um uh
lockdown and then trace
test track trace track and and
quarantine model um and and the
the probably the the most super
efficient form of that is china's
because it uses basically a surveillance
system that it uses for um
controlling a society to now track and
trace the coronavirus and um
uh so that's one model and then there
are democratic versions of that
germany south korea um etc and and
they've also been quite effective um uh
taiwan uh new zealand to name a few
at the other extreme um you have the
model being and by the way china is
doing that they hope to actually
completely quash
coven 19 in their society and and the
spread of transition until
there is a vaccine
because there's only you only can
overcome a virus like this when there is
hurt immunity and there's only two ways
to get hurt immunity one is through a
vaccine and the other is by 60 to 70
percent of your population actually uh
uh getting the infection and overcoming
it naturally by developing the
antibodies
excuse
me so uh
so that's um uh
that's the china model the second model
is the swedish model
and sweden while they don't like to say
it directly basically has gone for
natural herd immunity they their model
was actually keep their economy sort of
open close colleges and high schools but
let um k-12 school kk9 schools operate
um let malls and restaurants open uh but
encourage social distancing math
squaring and protect the most vulnerable
in theory which they didn't do very well
in practice actually let the young and
the least vulnerable those who will
experience this just as a mild flu
likely um uh or tough flu but will not
require hospitalization to get it
develop hurt immunity um and bet that
the number of people who will get the
disease and not require icu you know uh
units or ventilators will be less than
sign the number of icu units and
ventilators you have that's the swedish
model um and the uh the case is still
out there i mean we we just don't know
they've had a lot more deaths um than
their neighbors obviously they're
arguing that the real tests will be in
three months whether they have hurt
immunity and they're done with this and
not uh but you know there's a lot of uh
controversy around that and there's
simply no way to judge at this stage the
third model is america and we're a mess
sound um we basically um
uh
we talk like we're going to be china we
kind of act like we're going to be
sweden by default
um we are really not preparing to do
either
and our president's arguing we're
superior to both so it's kind of a mess
basically and you have some states where
it's where it's working well
others where it's working not well
people who are wearing masked people who
aren't and i go back to mother nature
because she actually doesn't know cell
where the border between georgia and
florida is
um and uh
she really is not interested in your
lockdown um or if you are tired of being
locked down um she really is only going
to respect your adaptation strategy
so what what i mean so what do you think
the implications are i mean just for the
us and the world i mean even for a china
or or even a sweden well i guess the
herd immunity could be very effective
but a place like china obviously at some
point they're going to want to open up
their borders so even if they are able
to squash it in the short term if to
your point mother nature also does not
know the borders of countries
you know if you just take a realist
point of view you know there's a world
where you advocate for one policy or
another but if you just say like the
world is kind of already on a trajectory
and you know there's going to be
political forces and economic forces at
play
what do you see as the next
6 to 12 months looking like you know
when you look at the stock market it
looks like you know at least the u.s
stock market looks like we're all clear
the things are things are things are on
i mean what's your your best guess as a
prognosticator yeah i read an analyst
the other day i said the stock market's
priced in everything except a recession
uh you know related to the uh to the
virus is quite remarkable but that's uh
it's in its own universe basically
um
what do i think is going to happen let
me start with what i'm praying will
happen i'm praying that moore's law will
defeat kovitz law that um uh basically
you got a race right now between moore's
law and kovitz law that you know kova's
law is about the speed with which one
single person can impact three others
and three others three others and how
quickly this virus can spread um moore's
law says the speed and power microchips
will double every 24 months and so
basically it's a proxy for technological
advance and since 1918 lord knows we
have technology tools now that we're
applying to biology that just didn't
exist before and um i'm hoping that they
will give us um a vaccine
or therapies at a minimum that will take
death off the table but a vaccine that
um uh by um you know the end of this
year early next year will allow us to
get through vaccine um uh a a high
degree of hurt immunity around the world
that's that's my hope um beyond that
it's really outside my skill set i
listen to what the biologists say the
virologist
that they expect
that this will we will get a second wave
we'll get a second wave in part because
people just aren't practicing uh smart
habits of social distancing and masking
and not collecting in in groups um uh
and we make it a second wave because the
thing about this disease which makes it
so beguiling is that you know first of
all it comes in uh it comes in decaf
regular and double machiatto and so
first of all
many people get it and are completely
asymptomatic and the next person next
you gets it and needs a respirator you
know and so it clearly interacts with
different bodies different dna different
co-morbidities different latitudes and
different populations and different
temperatures differently
and so
i think you just really have to respect
it and be humble
and so i listen to what the biologists
say and they're all basically telling us
there's going to be a second wave and
you listen to people like the
epidemiologist mike osterhome from the
university of minnesota and tom frieden
former tom frieden the former head of
the cdc um would just say that this
thing will just keep infecting us until
it runs out of people so
um unless we develop either natural or
or you know immunological herd immunity
so
um uh
a vaccine or immune so i i'm quite
humble about it sal i don't want to
i i i try not to get over my skis
and what's your sense you know given
even that somewhat hopeful picture of
hopefully we can get a vaccine near the
end of the year early next year i've
talked about there's talk about people
being able to have some type of
antiviral therapies maybe sooner that to
your point takes at least death off the
table but that still might be a november
time frame type thing
what do you think is going to happen
from kind of a economic and societal
point of view because even in you know
we've seen what's happened to
unemployment just over the last six or
eight weeks
if
what do you think is going to change
about people's behavior the economy you
know i don't want to get too much into
kind of the politics and who's doing
right or wrong but
you know what how might that broadly
affect uh you know politics
well it's a really important question
you're asking and and um
let me just talk a little bit about my
own life you know i'm i'm talking you
from our home in bethesda maryland um
uh my wife my wife ann's been building a
museum to promote reading and literacy
in washington dc it's called planet word
planetwordmuseum.org and um we were
about 90 done we actually were supposed
to open next week um so that's been put
on hold um and um
but here's what you know i have noticed
you know you and i are having
uh a conversation now um
via this technology is google technology
platform
um
and
i'd say sal it's about 85 as good as
when i used to come to your office and
you and i would sit there you know
across from your desk
but it's a hundred percent less stress
on you and me
and we're reaching a wide audience
and so i have been having
the most rich
um deep
uh zoom conversations now
around the world
um
i started this morning with um a friend
in mumbai
i'm doing this now with you it's just a
treat and then this evening i'm doing um
with a
friend from a consulting firm
i had a day a couple weeks ago where i
did the india today platform in new
delhi
um i then spoke to 82 u.n ambassadors
for the small ambassadors coalition at
the un and i ended the day with the bawa
form in beijing and i never left my seat
here at home
and these were not
um
facile interactions they were actually
they felt deep and so i um
uh
this chain this will change my world
this will enable me to
uh act globally you know when i wrote
the world as flat um what the book was
basically arguing is that um uh
what made the world flat the reason i
was making that argument was that what
we were seeing was not globalization
in the old days to be global you had to
be a country and then the old days to be
global you had to be a company what was
new that's what i was writing about when
i wrote that book in 2005 what was new
was the ability now individuals to act
globally sal and tom
are now acting globally
okay
um and as individuals and i think that
is only going to accelerate more and
more um
i want to hear from you
what this means for education
um uh and i've been talking to my
daughter early about that too obviously
this is this is really this not going
away because this technology is just
going to get better and better
and um uh you know i i can only imagine
so but i do believe we're going to see
more automation because machines don't
infect each other
um and we're going to see a lot of
companies realize
you know the new york times has been
closed from a pretty much the first week
in march we're closed they announced
we're not coming back to the office till
the end of uh summer until labor day at
the earliest that's includes the
washington bureau i work and and the new
york office
and you know i'm i'm proud to say we are
putting out the most amazing newspaper
every single day
and none of us are in the office now i
don't know exactly what the implications
of that are going to be but they're
going to be implications
um
and uh i'm just trying to get my mind
around that now
no i mean you're touching on a lot of
things i have to say a lot of people
they start calls these days and say how
are you doing and you know i say
relatively speaking i'm fine and you
know a lot of people are suffering much
more and i almost feel guilt that to
your point
i have there's aspects of this that i
think have been a huge have been a boon
they've not having i you know
i've talked about i don't enjoy planes
for a whole bunch of reasons i get
claustrophobic on them and all of that
but just the time the energy and then
being able to have fairly good
interactions with folks you know
all over the world like this
uh i think it is a new world and to your
point you know like the new york times
khan academy we are already we're
reasonably distributed but even more so
uh the the team is as functional as ever
i mean there's the main issues kids have
child care issue
team members have child care issues uh
while they're working from home but if
that was it wasn't an issue i think a
lot of folks are appreciating not having
the commute not having to get on planes
um and and so it is it is a bit of a
brave new world for for everyone uh that
maybe we'll have some positive
we're privileged i i have a job i work
for a healthy organization that not
laying me off and so i i understand what
a minority you know this is but in terms
of just how these technologies
are not going to go away i think they
will they're going to infuse throughout
our society and um and the longer this
goes on because the technologies will
get better the more more remote learning
remote work
um uh promote lectures i think will
become part of the norm
and i am curious about that last point
because i think both you and i we are
very fortunate we have jobs we can do
remotely
uh
we're you know we're which i think is
maybe one of the most important things
right now you know given how many people
especially in the service sector and
restaurants airlines tourism and now
other things you know people losing
their jobs
record high unemployment in our
lifetimes maybe ever we don't know when
this is going to end and to your point
it it might accelerate if if factories
lean even more on automation because you
can't transmit the virus and all that
what's going to happen to all of these
folks
how are we going to be able to make sure
that people stay engaged in in society
and they feel productive and you know
and and will it be temporary or will it
be somewhat structural even if we get
the vaccine
you know one of the points that um i i
did a dialogue one day with my friend um
michael sandel who teaches the justice
course at harvard and and um
we did a column together earlier on what
is the common good in a pandemic and
michael made this point it really struck
me you know you look around sal and
look at
all the people and all the jobs we are
now depending on people who go in and
stock grocery shelves people who go in
and and butcher meat at meat packing
factories people who drive the truck
um uh from the meatpacking factory you
know to the grocery store the processing
plant
um all the people who you know every
crisis throws up different heroes and
911 it was first responders and this one
is first responders too but now it's all
these people who who traditionally you
know it
it it wouldn't be wrong to say we're
looked down upon you know do your
homework study uh khan academy so you
don't have to be a truck driver you know
it would have been a cliche you would
have heard out there these people are
heroes now they're actually the ones
saving us
and um and by going to work they're
actually risking their lives think of
someone who sits in a grocery store all
day stocking shelves and we need to find
a way to honor these people after this
is over my my friend dev sideman says
you know right now we're busy you know
uh saving people but after this leaders
need to figure out how to serve people
we need to make a pivot after this and
make sure that um
these people
um uh have the kind of health care have
the kind of
family care child care and access to
education um that that they deserve that
everyone in our society deserves um
and that it's it's really got me
certainly thinking a lot more uh
about that and um i've never been a big
fan of universal basic income only
because i think dignity is so much
derived from work and working but um
you know
the way we've been dividing the pie uh
is not sustainable and um uh out of this
i think needs to come a real
a different division of the pie
more for labor than for capital um and
and safety nets that uh reward and honor
these people who we now find out
are so important um for the functioning
of our society
and what's your sense there's a question
there's a bunch of questions here from
facebook and youtube tim kearney asks
you know he's referring to your kind of
darwinian frame that you started with
you know if covet 19 is survival of the
fittest what responsibility does the
federal government have to support the
least fit and i'll add a little bit to
it because you know this kind of takes i
would say maybe a health angle the least
fit but also we as we just talked about
the economically vulnerable as well and
there is this really hard tension
that you might save people
uh with the shutdowns on the covet side
but it might lead to more poverty more
unemployment hunger and and and you know
all sorts of forms of death are
correlated with not having a job and not
and not having income so
how do you how does someone weigh that
how do you thread that needle
it's a it's a really important question
and i would say you know from the very
beginning and and uh in the beginning it
was controversial um i was one of the
very first people writing
that we need um the strategy we need
is one of what dr david cass called
total harm minimization how do we
maximize saving lives and saving
livelihoods because there's a lot of
ways to die
you can die immediately by coven 19 and
you can die long term by a death of
despair of unemployment of of loss of
hope and income and um uh and both are
thrown up by this these fires you know
sometimes people do say wow that sounds
really darwinian guess what it is when
when we're all in the grip of mother
nature it is there are no easy solutions
and the point is to respect to me both
sides of that equation how do we
maximize saving lives maximize saving
maximize saving livelihoods and it
seemed to me the way you do that and
this was what people like cats were
talking about amnon joshua in israel
basically you you lock down you break
the chains of transmission you protect
the most vulnerable um you literally
don't let them go out and you quarantine
and sequester them and then on a risk
stratified basis you feed back into the
workforce the people who are most likely
to experience the virus either
asymptomatically or um as a as a mild or
tough flu not require hospitalization
and let them keep the economy running or
or get it running again it had to be
that kind of a strategy one of the big
problems we have selling i'm not going
to get into politics uh here um any more
than uh i i need to but we haven't had a
national navigator you know um and so
basically the public here has been
caught between what i call breaking news
and president breaking bad okay so
you're watching the news and suddenly
breaks in and tells you that 24 kids um
in the new york area experience coven 19
as dramatic
and dangerous uh inflammations
but what you're not told is that 24 to
24 24 to 240 24 out of 2400 24 to 2 you
know 240 000. um if there's one lesson i
hope you're teaching it's the difference
between denominator and numerator and
when you don't know what the denominator
is and breaking news is constantly in
there hitting you with breaking news
that a 24 year old you know died of a
stroke or whatever and if you don't know
what is the denominator what is the
numerator how do i put this in
perspective so you have that on one side
and then you have a president who's not
wearing a mass using hydroxychloroquine
that his own fda rejects and putting out
crazy ideas about lysol and um
an ultraviolet light and so we have not
had like new zealand has had a calm
voice at the top
educating you uniting us making clear
that we're all in this together so don't
don't go to a restaurant
without a without a mask or crowded in
there that's not a sign of macho that's
a sign of disrespect to your neighbor to
your family to your grandparents you
know
this is not us against each other this
is us against all of us against mother
nature's fastball and and we really need
to think of it that way
now and a lot more questions coming in
facebook these are two related roger
stevens asks what are the biggest
societal changes you think we'll see
coming out of the pandemic and tim
kearney i teach first grade what type of
long-term changes do you foresee for my
colleagues and students how are they
how are they better or just are they
just necessary
how will they be temporary versus new
normal so it's really you know two
questions of you know what's going to be
the new normal we talked a little bit
maybe the nature of work changes maybe a
lot fewer people you know kind of schlep
into the office with that long commute
sitting in traffic maybe we travel less
which
frankly i i i would love um what are
what are other things that you think
might happen
so
you know one of the things i've been a
journalist now sell since 1979 so it's
my
my 40th year um and actually 78 i
started
um
and so if i look back at my career
the stories i'd most like to take back
the stories and columns began with this
sentence the world will never be the
same again
um that's a dangerous sentence you know
so i'm i'm humble about that too i want
to be very careful um but what is clear
to me is pandemics to accelerate
existing
uh trends
and they often um exacerbate existing
fractures and clearly they are going to
this one is going to accelerate
uh distance learning distance work and
replacing travel
with this kind of
teleporting telecommuting telemedicine
that um i think is just going to become
more and more effective and uh and
efficient and so um
i mean i've seen zoom presentations and
i know you can do it on this google
platform too now
with graphics and what it's just gonna
get so good
um that uh
you know that clearly that's going to be
a a an uber trend
um
beyond that you know uh it seems to me
another broad trend and this is a
phrase that my friend dov seidman uses
you know first we work with our hands
for generations millennia
then we work with our heads you know um
uh computing the information economy
and going forward more we're going to
work with our hearts
we're going to work with things that
connect people to people um and that
require people-to-people connections and
enhance people-to-people connections so
i have a motto you know if you're not in
the community business you're not in
business today you know
that is in the retail sense if you're
not creating a community experience
um uh
you are just the next company that's
going to be devoured by amazon you know
um uh because if all you have is kind of
a price arbitrage there's going to be
somebody bigger and more efficient at
that so um things that connect people to
people like i really love what we're
doing but i will love going out of this
and sitting around in my backyard with
with friends who can come over six feet
apart
even more after i've spent a day doing
this so i just think there's going to be
more and more work of connecting hearts
to hearts um and the machines um will be
doing the the the head stuff um my
friend ravi kumar who runs education for
um
uh info runs emphasis actually um the
indian high tech firm
um you know ravi basically says in the
future
um you know machines will do the problem
solving
and people will do the problem finding
um and that we and that's why emphasis
for instance is hiring fewer stem people
and more anthropologists and psych
majors and people who can
find problems you know that was steve
jobs genius he knew you wanted an iphone
before you knew it you know um and he's
the great example of that but problem
finders i think are going to be in great
demand and then we'll let the ai and the
machine and the bot
be the problem solvers i think that's
that shift is going to happen more it's
something you might want to be thinking
about it at con you know i mean
are we um we surely look you can't be a
good problem finder if you don't know
math and
and you aren't literate and and um and
you don't know history and whatnot but
but ultimately you know is that a vein
for khan
to be uh mining you know the idea of
problem finding
it'd be interesting to have a course in
problem finding yeah i've never thought
about it by the way but it makes a lot
of sense the problem definition and
recognizing there's a need now that
makes and maybe on that last point
because it does kind of touch on
careers of the future and all of that
you know i've been having a lot of
conversations with young people
it's graduation time you can imagine
there's a lot of anxiety there's always
anxiety at that age but especially in
this you know we have a couple of
questions uh from folks ashley pascal it
sounds like she's a young journalist you
know
how should she navigate her career
during kofi 19 but i'll broaden the
question you know what advice do you
have for young people uh kind of
entering the world into a very very
tough job market a world where things
are an incredible flux what advice would
you have for them
you know um
you know i i guess um
one of the things that
i said earlier this exacerbates um
current trends
so like if you are for instance look at
established journalists so i can just
call some up and say that's zoom you
know and um and you can call me up and
say tell them let's just zoom in bam we
do it it's like that but i i pity
someone who can't do that so zoom is
only good if i can call you up and you
will be the counterparty you know but
but um i i i this is such a challenging
time to start out in you know
at the same time because these things
always go both ways
it's like a whole new world
and you know there's such virgin
territory there to be reported on
um so many motherlodes of of emotion and
psychology now playing out and if you
can find
a platform to publish on an online
platform or somehow create your own
you you don't have to be at the new york
times you can break in now like never
before
and so my my
advice always for for young journalists
is that um
uh is write write write and and write
some more that is um the only way you
learn how to be a journalist is to write
and develop a
mountain of clips that show how you can
write the issues you can take on the the
um uh you know the stories you can frame
and find um and and that's how you build
a reputation
but um uh there's kind of no other way i
mean going to journalism school now
through zoom you know uh it doesn't
doesn't strike me as very productive so
um
i i i have a lot of sympathy for for
people starting out now i haven't my
mind's been elsewhere frankly for the
last couple of months but i i need to
think more about that it's a it's a very
good question but the the most important
thing you can do the thing that always
works is write and get published and by
the way it doesn't matter whether it's
for your neighborhood shopper
um your local community newspaper um
your blog your online just something
that can show your talent that you can
show to someone else for them to say hey
that that that was pretty good uh i'm
gonna give you a chance
and i'll add to that you know you're i'm
not a journalist you very much are a
journalist but some of the stuff that
you pointed out is stuff that i felt too
is that you know there's all this
reporting in the media but sometimes
people are like losing the meat of it
you know they're reporting this state
has this many cases that state has many
well what's the per capita like how how
at risk will i be they're losing that
you know yes there is a young person who
had this symptom and it's really scary
but you know give the context of guess
what there's always been
you know one in a million cases of
really horrible things happening so that
might not be that as different as
the media implies so you know whether
someone's going getting started in
journalism or any other field because
everything is thrown up in the air right
now there are opportunities to maybe
find niches to speak kind of in
evolutionary terms that might not have
been there before
our ancestors wouldn't have come out of
their holes if the dinosaurs weren't hit
by a
meteorite
so so so tom thank you so much for this
uh whenever we have a good conversation
the time goes un unusually fast we're
already overtime but um i really
appreciate this and i hope we can do
this again and we can have more of these
highly stimulating zoom conversations
absolutely sal thank you very much
thanks to all the people who tuned in i
really enjoyed it
thanks so much
so everyone thanks again you know as you
can tell these conversations are always
super fun for myself hopefully you all
have enjoyed it as well
i'm i've actually the reason why i'm in
the office all the socially distanced
i'm the only one in the office i don't
think they've turned the heat the air
conditioner on today so that's why i
might be looking a little bit more shiny
than normal um but it's always
incredibly stimulating for for myself
and
i look forward to seeing y'all in future
i guess we could call them episodes uh
tomorrow it'll just be just me and i'm
happy to take any questions you have
about anything
so with that i will see everyone
tomorrow
you